we got to begin with some breaking news
uh and not of the good sword overnight
uh coming out of russia where vladimir
putin is preparing for a longer and more
intense war on ukraine
in a speech carried nationally in russia
the president said he will put up 300
000 military reservists to active duty
this is president putin and warn western
countries to stay out of the conflict
the move follows a counter-attack in
northeastern ukraine that led to a
collapse of russian forces in that
region
and that's where we find deborah patta
she's in her kiev province one of the
areas where ukraine has made some very
big gains recently
deborah good morning
good morning tony well ukraine might
have seized back most of the territory
russia took at the start of the war in
kharkiv but vladimir putin is not
retreating stopping just short of
enforcing an all-out compulsory draft
today
vladimir putin's been pushed into a
corner
only reservists will be drafted he
announced today the priority those with
military expertise and experience
but it is putin who has come out guns
blazing warning the waste he still has
weapons of mass destruction read that as
nuclear and he's prepared to use them
we will use all the means at our
disposal to protect russia and our
people he said
this is not a bluff
with his back against the wall putin's
war is going very badly for him
this is how far ukrainian soldiers have
pushed back russian troops the nearest
russian border post just over two miles
down this road which is why we have to
be quick because even though this
village is liberated russian artillery
can still strike here
kazakhstan lapan was seized on the very
first day of the war the national
guard's third brigade is holding it down
but it is not easy
i think we have this fully under control
said unit commander nicknamed oplot the
enemy has fully retreated from this
territory is it totally free because
we're still hearing the sound of
artillery
is not to let the enemy ever enter here
again
both sides are still losing men in these
border towns and these fighters know
full well it's one thing to take back
territory quite another to hold onto it
permanently
now putin is also organizing referendums
in some of the occupied territories just
east of here to force through a vote to
become part of russia once that happens
it sets the stage for him to claim an
attack on those regions is an attack on
russia nate
deborah patta in ukraine thank you